another one of my first earlier American  films was a film called Princess Diaries  with Anne Hathaway in the great Julie  Andrews and that's the one you see a  vice-principal yes I feel great I went  to you know with actors you can go  through seasons and things I played what  at one point from the early to the mid  to the late 90s I pre-war detectives and  then I got a lot of teachers teachers  and then I moved into doctors but like a  lot and then I moved into a lot of like  a lot of people were wanting me to play  um like psychiatrists and therapists and  then I would have to be very very  judicious of how many doctors I would  play but yes this was the character of a  vice-principal and there's a line people  like you saying that movie and I haven't  seen it since but I remember it this is  a phone this is a form okay  I'm very good there's a very good mine  theater school huh the queen is coming  beautifully it moves me I've got  goosebumps  [Music]